never let anyone treat you like a yellow
Starburst you are a Pink
Starburst hi everyone I'm Paris Hilton
and these are my favorite
[Applause]
snacks that's hot so first up we have
some of my favorite
cereals cereals are literally one of my
favorite snacks I probably have cereal
every day every every morning sometimes
every night last night I had like five
bowls of Rice Krispies my trick
is I usually do this for the morning not
late at night sugar
[Music]
first R Krispies
then I love marshmallows so I basically
pick out all the marshmallows from the
Lucky Charms I found a better way to do
this because on Amazon they sell the
bags of just marshmallows so this is
like the old school way of doing it when
I was
little tastes so good I don't know what
you would call it I guess sliving crispy
charms this would probably taste good
inside of here
[Music]
too
scared loves it so next up we have
Starburst this is one of my favorite
candies but I only love the pink and the
red
ones so yellow and orange got to go I
remember when I was little we used to go
to the candy store for every Halloween
and anytime I would get Starburst I
would always eat all the pink and red
ones and I just remember my sister
getting annoyed with me being like
thanks you always just leave me the ones
that no one wants never let anyone treat
you like a yellow Starburst you are a
Pink
Starburst so next up we have another one
of my favorite snacks McDonald's french
fries with sweet and sour sauce and
[Music]
Sprite I have so many memories being a
little girl and I would be so excited if
my mom would take my sister and I to
McDonald's after school and I love
McDonald's so much but the night of my
wedding at midnight I had tons of the
fries brought in for everybody and
burgers and everybody just loved it
please cry they're
cold they're all really good hot like I
think with most fast food it's just
always good fresh I can't have my fries
without sweet and sour sauce like the
sauce is just epic during season one of
the simple life Nicole and I work at
this restaurant called Sonic it was a
lot of fun it was our first time working
at a fast food restaurant and we dressed
up in the mascot outfits for these giant
milkshakes and then we climbed up to the
sign and changed all the words of course
got in trouble for that and my favorite
part was wearing the roller skates and
serving everybody it was
fun so next up is my favorite pregaming
snack it's martini and
caviar and my favorite is the one by
Grey Goose and since I'm the new
creative director of The Grey Goose
classic martini cocktail it's pre-made
so all you do is shake or stir pour and
enjoy cheers so I love all my snacks but
sometimes I like a little luxury it's
very chic and little
Cal perfect for an awesome night of
sliving so next up we have strawberries
and
[Music]
Nutella this is the perfect date night
snack I love it so cute serving it on my
new cookware line which is a
heart-shaped shakery board and these are
just perfect for date night I call it a
sexy snack heat up the Nutella so it's
more melted kind of like dip the
strawberries in and like
it which I'm not going to do now cuz I'm
going to get it all over my face I'm so
excited for season two of my Show Paris
and love this season I start cooking for
my little baby boy he just started
eating solids so it's a lot of pureing
of vegetables and fruits it's fun to
cook for babies some of my sliving tips
for being in the kitchen or to wear
sunglasses while you're cutting onions
so it doesn't make you cry make sure to
put on an apron to cover your outfit so
you don't spill anything on it that's
[Music]
hot that was so much fun thank you for
watching me talk about my favorite
snacks and make sure to watch season 2
of Paris and love streaming on
[Music]
peacock